[Music]
where's daddy news a whole [ __ ] the
age-old question so many of I pull my
finger
the age-old joke no no I grew up with
the brother I know what that little
especially not your finger yeah we're
all gonna die before a woman used a
billboard to contact the man who got her
pregnant
and blocked her on Facebook put your
babies in the streets hell yeah that's
time big face she's like I'll get a
billboard yeah I wonder what you build
that's kind of tight it's like this dude
does anybody know who this guy is
and it's like a big picture of his face
that'd be pretty tight and they're gonna
share that [ __ ] all over cuz you know
people gonna take a picture of that [ __ ]
that's a good if it's like a picture of
the cabinet it's like he got me pregnant
and he won't talk to me like that's
pretty good yeah pretty much is so
here's the Billboard alternative I
thought it'd happen huh runaway daddies
exactly yeah yeah so it says Carlos
Carrasco Carlos it says my pregnancy
test came out positive I'm pregnant
he's [ __ ] back does that word mean
embarrass him but it's not that means
pregnant need to go under the hood and
review that one yeah that should be
embarrassed me on Facebook and my cell
phone by your friend and then in
parentheses it says that's how you would
introduce me I don't know what I whose
fault is is she [ __ ] them yeah do guys
change after or they've always been a
dick and in the girls [ __ ] up it depends
on how hot the girls always if the girl
is super hot you can hang with moles
pretend yeah there are some girls out
there that would tell you I'm the
biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever Nikki
probably wouldn't say that she'd say
like I'm pretty good dude right but
that's because like you know now she
just has positive things to say about
you she's hot right so I can hang with
some of these other chicks like I wasn't
digging it that much
but the things that she makes fun of you
about it like goes around and it bites
her in the butt like Bitcoin yeah you
about Bitcoin I know can you believe
that she made fun of me about that [ __ ]
it's pretty funny that's funny but other
than that no that's what her job is
I know what's your job to make fun of in
ridiculous I feel that way and then to
take credit for our success exactly well
warn you from doing successful things
and then once you become successful it's
like see I put you there well because if
we didn't push you away from it you
wouldn't want it more because you guys
are so dumb but it's kind of unfair
though because it's a win-win for you
guys for example if Nikki makes fun of
her about Bitcoin right yeah we're
genius so you may not make fun of them
but he's still gonna do it anyways and
now when he comes up he's forced by her
house why is Harper at the same time yes
you can chime in at any time but aren't
we genius yeah yeah and scandalous uh
whatever you want to call it genius is
so G wait wasn't just a hate about
Bitcoin he was a hater no it was that's
what you are I was a hater about the
Bitcoin [ __ ] mansion no no no but I
thought and that wasn't even hate that
was protecting that was a nurturer one
protective of scam what wasn't yeah
early hater no yeah no I wasn't that's
not what I heard I was never I heard hey
you're pretty happy
he likes to have good stories to tell
his friends but he just makes up [ __ ]
half the time for a long time and I can
vouch for that
exactly huh thank you huh you're still
gonna believe him over um I I don't know
he's a walking conscious she makes up
things are you gonna believe we have a I
got playing mafia right now I don't know
I'm gonna vote for I'm gonna vote for
uncle will kill Jess okay yep I'm not
voting for Jess no I'm Nessen don't vote
for her that's I'm saying don't vote for
her no I'm voting not to kill her oh I
thinking don't vote forever be President
it's like and during the night Jess was
killed the Mafia is still out there and
it's like ah goddamn it Joe yep yeah so
this billboard people are started taking
photos of it spreading on all over the
Internet
this [ __ ] Carlos that's the thing we
don't know
damnit I mean they could use a more
embarrassing picture Mexicans love to
gossip like that's how I know I'm
Mexican I hear some [ __ ] I never want to
like be a part of it but I do want to
know all the details I don't know if
that's a Mexican thing I think it's just
worldwide I think it the world yeah I
think so too I was just trying to give
us a little bit of [ __ ] credit please
credit for being awesome yeah we'd like
to spread the cheese Moses like gossiper
gossip Queens like a cheese thing sounds
great that's delicious
she sounds like a Taco Bell menu thing
she's mo so right with my gordita I
gotta figure out some of these words man
in bed as though though is pregnant that
sounds like embarrassment well you'll
probably like this one handcuffs in
Spanish just call this bull's ass which
is the same word for eight wives yeah oh
okay that makes sense it's like the ball
and chain thing yeah we don't have to
examine esposa also sounds like like a
dangerous yeah like good Mexican Danish
or something like oh look it's again
panada it's funny and I just like the
food so much that I think everything is
Mexican food yeah it's my favorite food
in the whole world
and but not a sound like a brass
instrument it really does where'd you
buy in Pinellas I like it
cut the vag on music story Tom it's the
local music store yeah could a big
guitar center like some did you still
play flute no that's right from you she
plans that she plays the recorder very
Clerk
up and down up and down is a recorder oh
yeah oh just smell that [ __ ] nope
you never clean that have you don't need
to look like a romance that [ __ ] out of
you tonight with this crime works better
I heard the magic thing Oh as soon as I
start crying starts sucking me off like
no tomorrow you should cry more I mean
I'm just she loves a salty dick series
for living - oh wow
tip that was dark I like that I like it
it's got a lot in her tears for Lube
that's like an old am handle yeah like
from extreme badass 13-year old me you
know and it has the upper case lower
case upper case lower case I think that
was just an Asian thing really no I
thought everyone did it all right I
don't remember all major presence did it
for sure yeah that's why I first saw I'm
like damn Asian people are [ __ ]
creative yeah so there were some people
they were saying that some citizens
consider the city one big Facebook wall
but it's not because in the real world
these things have consequences
there was this one lawyer that said that
to local media was the defamation it's
real
that's not definitely just pregnant it's
not yeah yeah but I guess like by
Mexican standards it is
well maybe not defamation but like
didn't publicly shaming shaming I mean
it's classless for sure but that's not
illegal
I think it's classless to leave the
chick pregnant exactly am i right I wish
I wasn't oppa right now in the hole I'm
hoping he's a good guy he's the only
good guy [ __ ] those dudes gross
he's like I would have never [ __ ]
busted wrong and a girl and left her
she's a beautiful woman oh you know I
can't do it we know you see a rich -
like rich enough to Fort Belvoir yeah I
wanted to know how much don't worry boy
but I can't find item I want a billboard
let's just get one let's all just pitch
in and do something random we don't want
to build our voids do ya when I'm a
millionaire why why the [ __ ] wouldn't I
buy a Super Bowl commercial yeah are you
kidding I support you right yeah
everybody's watching well together we
did a Super Bowl commercial what do we
do I said millions of dollars it's like
five mil yeah for like 34 do I sign
exactly and we do whatever the [ __ ] we
want
it's probably 30 it's 30 seconds to a
minute it could be a minute I don't know
the exact what if we're all just facing
the camera and pink it could be no you
screw your squatting
we all know that you're in the painting
video we all know that we've seen you on
the toilet take it down so you couldn't
have gotten millions of you know it's
still up it's on people's hard drives
once on the internet always only it kind
of monetize a little bit better but yeah
this is before their flag and everything
I would do [ __ ] like that if I was rich
as [ __ ] I would absolutely do that
so just peeing no not I'm not peeing I
you know well make them watch me eat
[ __ ] chips for 30 seconds come on
exactly you just it eat slowly eat a
steak just cut it with a knife
oh that psychopathic dude right if I saw
that it'd be like is it what I mean what
are they telling ya I feel uncomfortable
but the last second you go Pringles and
that's it yeah exactly you do something
random yeah something that that has no
brand though it has to have no brand
that's what that one or am a nut bread
or made-up thing yeah the Billboard
though I'm in it I feel like we can do
that tomorrow and it's just a picture of
us like just pointing and giving them a
compliment or something thank you look
at today we can totally get a billboard
right now but that's so nice why would
you do that is I want to spend spread
positivity in such a negative ass time
yeah I don't know or you could do it a
lot of people were doing and do
something so outrageously dumb that you
unite people by hating on it little bro
do you think yeah this is JK news I mean
I feel like we'd do that already so I
wanted more of that we're smart though
keypoint you're brought United because
we're smart right uh all right like we
should do a thing where it's like a
billboard for like a
new food truck that we're doing but it's
all dog meat but we're excited about it
you in dog festival [ __ ] and it's not
it's not the garbage eat human dog
festival stuff like the corn like these
shitty little Korean dogs right not that
stuff we got the gold with the golden
retriever me yeah version of doggie and
they're and they're raised responsibly
all family dogs
none of this part shaded [ __ ] they had a
great life with a great fam
I like that before the vicious have you
had me you really have lost me with the
dog me no way we're all about to sign no
but this like you guys were saying like
to get a bunch of people angry at us I'm
excited about it as a family-owned
business like you know it's like imagine
like a little baby with the floor yeah
and it's like aw like oh don't worry
it's all family operated no [ __ ] and
everyone's like that's not the problem
the problem is the dog meat yeah I just
love oh that's the kind of [ __ ] I would
do but wait wait wait we don't use
preservatives exactly it's all naturally
raised what he wants a family dog what
more do you want we should serve hot
dogs - oh God we could say they died of
old age for all I know sometimes like
Nicky's always like I don't know about
this one cuz the way they treat the
animal whatever and I'm like dude at the
end they [ __ ] blow them away however
they do it it's pretty nuts looking
right yeah we could do local like
distribution like you know how like some
nights at Pasadena Humane Society
there's so many canines that get you
know euthanized every week so it's like
what are we doing with all this meat
yeah or we could just say they died of
old age and they died of happiness or
some [ __ ] you know and just then it's
like what's left or I'll never eat a dog
only sell them see I don't even know how
to jump in on that that just blew my
mind
[Music]
[Music]